大家好
我们又见面了
哈哈哈哈哈啊
欢迎来到games202
然后这也是我在games所讲授的第二门课啊
Real time high quality rendering
叫做高质量实时渲染
那么今天我们给大家说我们的第一讲
第一讲大家都知道这是任何一个课程
第一讲基本上就是随便说一说对吧
咱们大家聊聊天啊
基本上就是这么个意思
然后简单跟大家说一说呃
然后呢大家首先会关注到两个事情
第一大家会看到我不在静香的啊
比如说大家现在看到的这是我的右手啊
这回没问题了
对吧
我们的这个直播方式得到了巨大的升级啊
另外一点就是我们现在不需要在中间转一趟
SKYPE的这种呃
就是这个中转过程了
然后咱们现在就直接可以播
非常好嗯
OK然后嗯另外一点呢
大家现在从这第一页就可以看出来了
咱们这课难度升级从哪地方看出来呢
只是配色方案就可以看出来了
逐渐黑化对吗
然后之前大家可以看到是白底黑字的
现在是灰底白字的
然后当然了啊
我是怎么想的呢
是这个意思
就是作为咱们的基础课来说
肯定有很多同学啊会去呃利用它去去学习一下
然后应付一下考试或者干什么
然后涉及到这个呢
作为我当年本科的时候也有这种习惯
就是把这些PPT啊什么东西打开打出来对吧
打出来的话呃这样的话看起来比较方便吧
但是对于这门课来说
不可能有人考你的啊
这个意思
所以说我觉得就这么放了
然后正好还护眼
还没有打印的必要啊
咱们正好接受了一个新的配色方案啊
非常好
哈哈哈哈行
然后呢大家可以看到啊
我通常会把课程内容做成几个大的这个图
放到咱们的PPT里面
然后这些都表示什么呢
我待会儿会挨个说
没问题
那咱们首先就正式开始咱们的games202
首先欢迎所有的同学们
然后不管你之前是否支持过games101啊
然后只要你来听这门课啊
高质量实时渲染
我都非常非常的欢迎
然后呢大家看到这个logo啊哈哈
然后嗯做的非常好
不过有没有同学吐槽这个logo让大家看了一眼
就觉得我们这课是不是被罗技鼠标赞助过
当然没有哈哈没有
但是可以有哈哈
我这么说一下啊
然后嗯这样啊
其实哎先跟大家说句抱歉哈
之前咱们不是说北京时间上周六咱们就直播嘛
然后由于我这边工作原因啊
有点忙不过来
所以说咱们跳票唉
所以说从飘飘的角度上来考虑
咱们这个welcome给大家改成这么一个画面
好了
不管怎么样啊
欢迎大家来学习games202啊
然后呢我会把我所知道的东西都告诉给大家
那么我是谁呢
呃我叫闫令琪
然后我是UCSB的啊
教授啊
然后这里大家可以看到我的呃学术主页
我的邮箱
欢迎大家联系我
然后我个人所做的科研大家可以看到正式渲染
然后不管是离线还是实时渲染
然后渲染呢自然是属于计算机
图形学中间的一部分好的
然后呢啊呃我个人的一些爱好啊
大家会看到诶爱好第一条是科研啊
这呃是这么回事
就是说我是觉得啊就是作为能够找到一份工作
这份工作呢和自己兴趣是完全能够吻合的
但我觉得是一个非常幸运的一件事情啊
不只是工作了
包括学习的时候
比如说我自己读博士的时候
我就很喜欢我做的这个方向叫真实感啊
图形学染啊
然后呢我就觉得哎过得非常开心
然后包括现在来说
能够嗯把自己的这些呃
科研工作做出来了一些东西
然后展示给大家
然后呢这边再给大家带来一些这些呃课程
能够帮助到大家
那我就非常开心啊
没问题
所以说作为呃一项爱好
这是科研啊
好的
然后呢
呃我个人是一个非常非常非常严重的网瘾诶
这不是少年了
网瘾大叔了哈
我是大叔啊
然后这这这这是我我这边打游戏
打的非常夸张的那些
之后会看到我的知识储备
OK我估计比你打的多啊
如果没错的话
然后我个人弹一点钢琴呃
然后平常看NBA
平常呢呃有时候出去玩
如果不是因为疫情的话啊
唉想到想到疫情
我就想起了这个事情啊
去年啊去年大家如果上过games101
就会知道说呢我给大家播games101
是所谓大家团结一致共抗疫情啊
结果现在大家这差不多在国内抗击疫情
已经取得了圆满的成功
结果我现在还在隔离
我已经在家呆了一年了
我的天哎哈哈哈哈哎呀
好吧行啊
然后呃这差不多呢
这就是我的一些简单介绍
然后还是一样啊
这介绍一下我的成就
我们然后之前曾经2019年
我拿过一个所谓呃西格raft的最佳博士论文奖
然后呃同样2019年
然后呃我做的那个不是我做的哈
就是我提出的模型被应用在一部电影里面
就是狮子王的HD啊
这之前咱们在呃games101里面
已经自夸过了是吧
然后呢呃大家会发现没有什么变化对吗
如果奔嗯去年的games101相比
是不是还是这些是的
然后包括其实我要说的最后一条也是
然后包括我在吃鸡领域取得的成就
在2020年也没有任何的突破啊
还是在2019年创下了记录
六杀哈
虽然伤害倒是提高了啊行吧
反正这是啊
我感觉2020年就好像是这
这这莫名其妙就没了
然后我在想2020年我干了什么呢
感觉挺忙的
结果什么事也没干对吧
这么个意思哎行吧
没关系啊
嗯那咱们现在继续
然后我来介绍一下啊
我们的课程呃
现在呃呃很荣幸能够找到以下的三位同学
当我们的助教万建周同学
周锦超同学和邓俊成同学
然后呢呃在这门课发布助教招募信息的时候啊
有很多朋友们啊
以及包括已经工作了的啊
朋友们发来各种各样的邮件
然后大家都非常非常厉害
然后由于咱们这个games的这个非营利性啊
大家考虑到呃这一点
所以通常就会只会在当前的学生群体中来选择
所以在这里呢先跟大家呃
如果说呃你之前提交了助教的申请
然后呃没有被选上
没有任何关系啊
然后向大家说一声抱歉啊
这个意思
然后呢在这门课的进展过程中
我们会根据需要还是一样
从现在的学生群体中看
能不能在招募更多的助教
同学们好吧
那这就是咱们现在的呃
这个阵容相当于是啊
那在我来说这门课程之前
我先来听一下啊
我看大家弹幕里面会问到一些什么问题好吧
嗯嗯嗯嗯可以挺好的啊
好像啊这些这些没有什么特别学术的问题啊
就先这样吧
嗯好的
那么我就先继续了好吧
OK那咱们这就开始关于这门课呢
那首先肯定要说咱们这门课是是是干什么的
对吧
咱们这门课叫real time high quality rendering
那自然而然大家可以看到三个关键词
就分得非常清楚
real time对吧
实时high quality高质量
然后rendering是渲染
那么这门课呢
首先就是有同学会会关心这么一个事情
他作为一二开头的课会不会非常难
我的理解是这门课不会非常难
为什么呢
他之所以被列为用二开头啊
仅仅是因为它存在一个依赖关系
他需要games101的知识
但这并不代表这门课就非常难哈这个意思
所以我觉得呢他只是说把这个基础的知识啊
然后我们再想办法去取得一个好的
或者更实际的一种应用
所以我管它叫进阶的啊
层级吧
就是不是特别的难啊
这个意思好啊啊
甚至真的我说句实话
很可能这这这门课的绝大多数内容不会比
pass racing on man啊
这是大家关心的一个问题
那么咱们现在回到这门课的标题上来
Real time high quality rendering
咱们来分别解释一下好吗
首先real time
咱们来强调一下real time
real time是什么意思呢
real time指的是一种速度
好吧
是一种速度
就是说你不是要做渲染吗
你要做到一个什么样的级别
我才能说它叫实时的呢
通常人们会认为做到30FPS
这就叫real time
什么叫30FPS
是指每秒钟生成30幅图
所谓一个frame其实就是一张图啊
Frames per second
简称FPS
所以只要你能够达到或者超过30FPS
我们就管这样的一种速度叫做实时
然后呢
呃实施呢当然在不同的领域有不同的定义
比如说像这个啊虚拟现实和增强现实这边的
他们会认为说呃可能对实时的要求会更高
比如说要达到90FPS
然后我们就认为30FPS没有问题
好吧呃
呃另外呢在这里再跟大家说另外一个速度
就是说呃大家有时候说哎我打游戏
我觉得特别卡
就好像播幻灯片一样
哎那种感觉肯定是低于30FS
对不对
而那种呢我们会把那样的一种速度
大概每秒钟生成个几帧
这种速度叫做interactive
也就是说
interactive是一个比real time要稍微慢那么一些的
但是呢他又不至于特别慢
比如说你这边点了渲染之后
然后你这出去遛弯回来
他还在渲染
这是不可能的对吧
就像看幻灯片一样
但是基本上来说还是可以接受的
这种就叫做interact呃
呃interactive呃
FPS啊
这么一个速度好
然后呢实时渲染讲究的是什么呢
讲究的是所谓啊这叫什么呢
叫互动性
就是这么个意思
就比如说大家在玩游戏的时候
大家按了一个键
立刻那边就可以得到反应对吧
你在屏幕上看到说你的角色在发生移动啊
那这就是说real time做到的
那否则的话你要等他去渲染对吧
那这肯定要花很长的时间
所以说这就是首先我们要说的啊
real time的事情好
然后呢下面我们来解释一下high quality
那这门课为什么一定要强调high quality呢对吧
首先我是在想啊
这门课我是可以说呃
可以管它叫什么现代实时渲染入门的啊对吧
但是那样的话包含的信息其实不如这么多啊
呃所谓high quality指的是什么呢
指的是真实感
这是真实感
就是咱们之前在games101
如果你上过这门课的话
你会知道说我们渲染的最终的目标是什么对吧
是以假乱真
但在这个呃以假乱真这么一个目标下
你要付出的代价是什么
那很可能就是高额的计算没问题吧
你要花大量的时间去计算
然后去算出来最后的结果才能让他更加真实
但是我们所说的这门课
他所做的事情就是这样的
就是说为了保证实时渲染
然后通常大家都会去牺牲一些质量
大家是不是觉得这个是很熟悉的一个事情
没错吧
我在games101经常说的trade off
就是这么一个意思对吧
然后但是实时渲染就体现了人类的另一个美德
那就是贪婪对吧
人类想说的事情就是我全都要
对不对
我又要高质量
我又要实时
然后我怎么样诶把这个事情给做出来
那这就是实时渲染最大的一个挑战
然后咱们在之后的这些不同的不同的什么呢
不同的题目或者说呃任务中吧
咱们之后会体会的更清楚
好吧好
然后呢呃high quality另一面当然是说
如果你为了让他要真实
那你肯定就要保证它在物理上是正确的
或者是近似正确的
而这一点之后还是一样
我们会着重的来体会这个事情
当然同时他也要求说
你不能说跑坏掉了一些东西
比如说你的嗯每一帧吧
假设说你会随机坏掉一个像素
然后大家会发现那这个正确率基本上9%
19.9之类以上的对吧
但是当你把它作为一个动画给播出来的时候
每秒30帧
那就非常非常难以让人忍受
所以说像这一系列的这些啊
所谓的artifact
咱们在M4101里面说过对吧
就是无法控制的一些失误出现错误
像这些东西通常在实时渲染中
它会有一个更高的要求
好吧
就是说通常大家不愿意这些事情发生
好嘞
那这就是基本上来说
我们对于这两个事情的解读啊
real time和high quality
当然rendering啊
这个事情大家是非常熟悉了对吧
大家已经知道rendering呢
他是在图形学下面的一个重要分支
它所做的事情是什么
他所做的事情是把一个3D的一个一个场景啊
然后我们把它给通过计算方式
然后呃通过这种计算方式去模拟光线
是如何从呃光源中发出
并最后呃在在场景中弹射之后
进入人类眼睛的对吧
我们在试图模拟说虚拟的一个摄像机
如何看到一个虚拟的场景
那么这就是一个渲染的事情
大家看到这个例子
大家还是很熟悉的
对不对
只不过我画了一幅图哈哈
大家可以看到右边
这个自然就是我们可以理解城市渲染的场景
虽然它是一幅照片啊
然后这是我这一年中为数不多的成就之一
我在家练了一下这个咖啡的拉花
然后虽然现在还不怎么对称啊
但是好像还还可以对吧
多少有这形状
而且大家可以看到这是CIRA2014的杯子
这是我头一次啊
我人生中头一次
我博士的一年级去参加这个SIGGRAPH
然后当时买了这个杯子纪念品啊
一直用到现在
哈哈哈哈哈哈好吧
然后啊
那这就是关于rendering啊
那咱们这样就把这门课这几个三个关键词
解读清楚了
那么大家自然而然要问的事情
就是这门课到底我们会讲哪些话题呢对吧
那首先呢大家自自然从这封面图上就可以看到
我们会讲四个话题
哪四个话题呢
阴影对吧
然后全局光照
然后呃然后其实这块儿对
差不多就是可以认为是认为是呃
呃真实真实的着色或者基于物理的着色
然后以及最后的一块啊
呃实时光线追踪啊
咱们大概分成这么四块来表示啊
但是呢但是呢这门课跟之前的games
101的一个重大的一个区别吧
就是说它的知识点相比于games101
是非常分散的
就是说他的很可能就是基本上这两节唉
咱们讲这么一个题目
然后下两节咱们讲另外一个题目
就变成了一个专题研讨会形式的一个课程
就是和之前所谓的这种一下读下来
这么前差不多十节课
然后咱们可以手写一个啊
最基础的一个软光山话
这叫什么来着
阮光山漆还是叫什么
就soft呃
Where restaura
对吧好吧
没关系吧
就是反正呃这点呢是和之前的呃
电影Z11不同的地方
所以呢大家会在这门课上的过程中会体会到
这左右横跳是一个非常正常的一个事情
知识点非常的分散
好吧啊
OK那大概都包括哪些内容呢
简单给大家过一遍
那么哪些呢
呃首先关于阴影和呃
阴影和和环境光啊这块算是同一个话题吧
让大家可以看到一个跳舞的小机器人啊
非常有趣
呃然后呢这个环境光之前我们说过对吗
这是可以描述来自环境的
从四面八方过来的光照
然后就非常复杂
可以投射出绝对不止一个阴影
然后特别是在这种动态的物体下
你怎么样把它给做出来呢
对不对好
然后另外一个呢就是实时嗯
呃确切说这里不是实时了
这里大家可以看到用的词就是interactive啊
全局光照
大家知道我们刚才才说对吗
interactive差不多每秒有个几帧对吧
差不多或者甚至每秒一帧
然后两秒一帧都没什么关系
这些我们就管它叫interactive
就不是特别慢
但是还不错啊
然后呃这些呢实时渲染的一些技术
然后包括不需要预计算的
以及通过一些预计算做了一些所谓trade off的
我们在我们在这门课之后会说
就比如说大名鼎鼎的球面斜坡函数
然后在这些呃在这些预计算的这些过程中
起到的这种关键作用哈
就是说我们如何通过呃去嗯
在渲染之前花费一些时间
并且花费大量的存储
使得我在渲染的时候能够达到一个
更好的实时渲染好吗啊
OK那没问题
那另外呢
当然我刚才提到说呃实时的光线追踪对吧
大家现在看到的这个例子
大家看到哎我们基本上可以达到10FPS啊
这个不算什么real time嘛
但是啊我跟大家说一说这个背景
这个呢是我若干年前我已经不记得了
这是我写的一个demo啊
这是当时呢还没有光线追踪的硬件
当时这个硬件是什么呢
我是在什么上面跑的呢
应该是GTX780啊
大家可以想一想
基本上是上古时代的这些硬件了哈
然后做到这么一个速度
然后这也是当时算是嗯嗯可能是最早吧
然后证明了说实时光线追踪是非常可行的啊
然后咱们这门课里面呢
会把这这系列研究的思路给说清楚
然后就是关于实时渲染
实时的光线追踪到底是怎么回事
它怎么发展的
然后现在大家的一个主流的做法是什么
那我们肯定会说好吗
然后呢关于一些啊
嗯比如说我们刚才提到的一些真实感的材质
然后特别是包括一些散射介质
或者叫参与介质
Participating media
然后这些的这些渲染就比较难了
就是大家看到这一幅呃
所谓single scattering什么意思呀
对吧
待会儿之后我们会给大家说
这是应该也是虚幻引擎里面能够做到的效果吧
然后还有一些杂项的一些内容
比如说在图像空间做的一些操作
比如说呃
大家可以看到这个水面会反射出来这些呃
这些建筑物对吧
这些东西都是怎么做的呢对吧
这些是一些实现软件也在解决的一些经典问题
我们也会提
然后呢呃关于非真实感渲染
然后我们也会提一下
大家可以看到非真实感渲染
咱们可以用一款国产游戏来代表它
那就是原神啊
然后咱们抛开它的盈利模式不谈
然后就单讲画面来说
我觉得这样说可圈可点啊
真的是不错
然后呃呃当然哈这个也没
我也没有得到任何什么米哈游的赞助啊
这当然也可以有啊
嘿嘿嘿嘿嗯好的呃
这是这么说啊
然后呃这里大家会看到这些事啊
关于非真实感渲染的话
呃我个人不是特别愿意去多说啊
虽然他很重要
这个没问题啊
为什么呢
是因为非真实感渲染嗯
它存在很多的这种非科学性啊
我是这么觉得
就是说你希望他做到一个什么样的效果更多啊
它是由最后你要的艺术效果来决定的
所以说呢更多情况下你是在写一些什么if else啊
有很多这些这些类似的这些判断哦
说到这里我跟大家说一说
这是我的理解哈
就是说我最早在在接触这个呃非真实感渲染
或者说NTR的时候啊
然后我觉得诶这不就是不同的这些case
然后我去写不同的这些if什么东西不就行了嘛
啊这是第一阶段
第二阶段是我学的比较深入了之后
我发现不是我发现很多东西啊
你这这块写了衣服之后
另外这边要怎么办对吧
然后然后就有可能这属于属于说你写的SHADER
是拆东墙补西墙的一个情况
这是第二阶段
然后目前的我我又回到了第一阶段
或者说是我上当了
第三阶段
我觉得我觉得他还是一副else
所以到时候这样吧
就不管怎么样哈
我把我的呃理解
到时候都告诉给大家好吗啊
OK那没问题
那这里呢呃原神
当然去年整个一年肯定有很多同学一样还在啊
记得被鲈鱼支配的恐惧对吧
如果你是动森玩家的话
呃这幅图来说
应该是应该是非常非常非常熟悉了对吧嗯好的
然后呢
呃当然这肯定是大家从画面上来看
飞机的真实感
图形渲染嘛
对不对
但是也是这非常卡通的
非常好看
很有意思的对吧
然后呢呃那咱们还会说什么呢
呃这门课上啊
还会说一些比较稍微现代化一点的话题
比如说在实时光线追踪的背后啊
它其实是一些跟这些所谓spatial temporal
也就是空间和时间空间呃的这么一些呃方法呃
他们的发展啊特别有代表性的
就是现在的呃temporal antasy
也就是时间上的啊
抗锯齿技术
然后包括其他的一些抗锯齿技术
我们都会说一些啊
就是呃以及包括这之前
咱们在101上已经跟大家说了的啊
就是super sampling嘛
就是比如说NVIDIA的DLSS呃技术
可能我们会说的稍微更详细一些
这个时候我们到时候再看时间吧
好吧啊
那为什么会这样
就有一些我会多说
有些我会少说
我们待会儿再给大家解释好吗
呃然后呢关于这门课啊
特别是今天啊
今天没有什么特别重要的内容啊
我呢主要是愿意跟大家聊一聊
各种各样不同的现在的这些技术
比如说大家呃
有很多同学肯定已经看了这个demo了对吗
这是虚幻引擎五的一个呃一个演示视频呃
非常夸张的这个技术啊
大家可以看到洞穴里面呃
这里面投影嗯
嗯就是说可以被照到的
这个区域只有这么一小块
然后呢但整个洞穴都是亮的对吧
这肯定是嗯大家之前如果学过games
101都会很清楚对吧
就是说这是这是呃在实时渲染中非常困难
就是不好做的地方
就是global illumination
也就是全局光照
然后以及包括当然了
在这个虚幻引擎五里面
一个着重展示的技术
是他如何可以啊
处理一个场景中上衣的三角形啊
确实应该不是上一个三角形
应该上10亿百亿个三角形
它们如何在呃实际中去做出一些呃
动态的几何的取舍对吧
然后像这些啊
虽然跟渲染来说稍微离得远那么一点点哈
但是我还是愿意跟大家聊一聊
之后看咱们穿插的时间来了
嗯比如说啊这里我就可以先跟大家说一下
就是说之前其实我我我在嗯在什么时候呢
在这个虚幻引擎五刚出这个demo的时候
有同学找到我说
想想让我说一下它背后的这个技术
它它是怎么实现的对吧
然后啊我的理解其实是这样的
就是说对于这些引擎来说
我们待会儿也会说引擎来说更多更多的内容
它并不是说在学术上是非常难的一件事情
它难在哪儿呢
它难在它本身引擎是一个系统
它有大量的工程的东西在里面
比如说你问我
他是如何去做这个几何的
这种简化的
包括这块呢这个制作者他们自己发的嗯
叫什么twitter啊
上面就已经讲的挺清楚啊
就是相当于是用啊
呃呃就是之前啊
大名鼎鼎的顾先锋老师的几何图像啊
几何图像之后我们会说这是一个经典技术啊
和什么呢
和一个虚拟纹理的结合对吧
这我一想大概是这么做的
没问题
然后呢包括他的嗯这些实时实时的这些啊
全局光照是怎么做的呢
那像这些就是一些基于屏幕空间的一些方法
然后像这些方法呢
我们课程其实都要讲
也就是说他在背后的科学并没有那么难
那真正难的东西是什么呢
是技术啊
这个我们在待会很快就要跟大家说
我认为我个人认为
科学和技术是两样截然不同的事情
以这个游戏引擎为例
那么它背后所运用到的科学知识是非常简单的
或者说是经典的
是在大概10年前像这样的一些知识
但是他用的技术却是非常先进的
或者咱们反过来这样说
如果要让你来写这个可以
你写的出来只是会比他慢个十倍100倍左右
是这么一个意思
明白了吗
所以游戏引擎的时候的的话啊
它背后其实并不是特别难的一个事情啊
他只是说本身在写的时候啊
这是哈哈哈哈
OK好吧
然后关于这个背后
至于具体是怎么做的呢
咱们之后再看吧
因为我毕竟我也不知道对吧
只能从它的外表
这个是上面来考虑
来了来猜测一下啊
另外再跟大家说一下
我们的某一次作业
是要山寨一个这样的全局光照好吧
然后我们先说清楚啊
质量呢可能是比不上他的
但是不管怎么样
在背后的科学
还是我刚才说的这个事情是对的好吗好嘞
那这就是啊
今天这是扯的一首啊哈哈
OK然后呢
我还愿意在这门课程跟大家探讨探讨游戏啊
因为什么呢
因为实时渲染这嗯就这个领域吧是百分之
我就说90%以上都是由游戏的需求
来推动的
这个大家不反对吧
应该没问题对吧
然后我觉得这是嗯游戏的发展
基本上大家就可以从游戏的发展就可以看到
说实时渲染的这么发展
我们马上待会儿也会看好吧
然后这里呢大家可以看到呃
这个呃最后生还者二啊
然后这这个名字其实有很多地方
值得吐槽的对吧
比如说哎大家可以看到哈哈哈哈
也可以看到有很多很很多同学不喜欢这个哎
最后生还者二的剧情
然后管他叫高尔夫二啊
至于为什么这就不剧透了啊
然后这个翻译本身呢
也是非常恶意满满的一个翻译哈
它叫the last of us
然后由于他的封面写的是全大写
所以翻译成中文的时候
有人把它按照了last u s来翻译
翻译成美国末日哈哈不过也挺贴切的哈
那个时那个时代确实是美国末日
呃挺有意思的
不管怎么样吧
这是一个啊
咱们这样说
不管怎么样
现象级的游戏啊
就是画面是非常好的
然后呃剧情是饱受争议的
然后还是很多东西值得怎么说呢
探讨一下好吧
然后之后呢我我我说过嘛对吧
我自己作为一个
这这这个打了很多很多年游戏的人
有很多东西是可以跟大家说的
以及呢
比如说哎咱们呃
最近最近肯定是很多同学跟我一样
是对这么一款游戏叫做呃怪物猎人崛起啊
是非常期待的对吧
然后差不多十天之后也就要发售了啊
然后大家可以看到啊
这幅截图就是我现在打这款游戏的demo啊
第二阶段demo的真实写照啊
哈哈哈哈哈哎呀好吧
然后嗯对吧
同学们有有有有真的
这打过了怨虎龙的
同学们肯定有对吧
唉呀唉我来看看啊
按说是有延迟的好吧
没有怨虎龙都没打过
你还来这听听什么网课
对不对啊
本末倒置对不对
哎哎得我就随便说一说
OKOKOK行吧
之后有空
咱们在课程中再给大家穿插
关于游戏的一些讨论啊
这么着好的
那么这门课呃不讲什么啊
这也是大家觉得呃很关心的一个话题对吧
首先呢跟games1011样
咱们有两点不会讲
第一怎么样去去做这3D的建模啊
第二怎么使用游戏引擎啊
这点我说清楚怎么使用游戏引擎
是绝对不会说的
比如说像像虚幻引擎
它有什么什么层啊
什么节点啊
这些是一概不会不会提这些东西
为什么啊
我来解释一下
就是我认为哈这些内容是属于说呃
那是别人开发出来一套系统
你要学它是怎么用
所以说学长怎么用
你基本上只要看教程
或者说现在对吧
有很多已经有了的课程
然后各种各样的文档大家自己看
然后需要的是累积一些经验
把它给用熟
就好像是用PHOTOSHOP一样
对不对
用PHOTOSHOP这个事情呢
是这个相对来说相对
你要理解说它背后的这个钢笔工具怎么用
那当然是一个相对简单的事情
所以我不提这个事情
是因为呃有其他的课程和我们的这个课程是呃
呃交叉的啊
是这么个意思好吧
呃呃所以说这块呢我不再提
那么有同学就说
那这样的话啊
我们实时渲染这些作业中间我学到的这些东西
可以把它用在这虚幻引擎里面
开发这些SHADER什么东西吗
可以没问题
你所缺的就是一些所谓工程上的一些知识
而这块呢也是自己之后是需要呃需要自己去呃
靠大量的经验积累
然后实战把它给做出来了
没问题吧
那我这样说
那从一个更高一点的角角度上来说
我个人能力有限
但是我希望把我所知道的这些
跟实时渲染相关的背后的科学都教给大家
然后大家做完了之后
肯定会有比我更出色的工程师们
然后一起来把这个呃
呃这这这比如说咱们国产的自研的引擎
能够给做的非常好
甚至可以超过现在的呃虚化对吧
这些是我的梦想啊
我希望这门课对大家的一个帮助啊
好嘞
那这基本上来说呃
就是我说为什么咱不讲这个啊
同样什么东西不讲呢
呃不讲的是是离线渲染啊
离线渲染咱在咱们这门课中呃是不太会说的啊
比如说吧
大家看到一些比如说复杂的光线传播呃
想呃这些方法
这些方法我为什么提这个事情呢
是因为说我个人理想当中啊
渲染应当是有三门课啊
作为图形学入门的games
101可以算是一模告诉大家这些基础
然后实时渲染和离线渲染
应当是作为两个分支来分别来说的好吧
然后离线渲染的话之后
我再考虑是不是要开课吧
就是说离线渲染的话讲起来那可就真的难了哈
那就不像呃实时渲染这样这样一个难度了啊
OK那咱们至少咱们这门课先不说
先放在这
另外呢我不说什么呢
还不会说呃
所谓这块我从来没中文翻译过
难道真的要翻译成神经渲染吗
叫neural rendering啊
我平常就管它叫neural rendering啊
那就这么说
那么大家看到的这么一个例子
是目前来说
一个NEURRUNNY做的非常好的一个例子
然后叫做呃叫做NERF啊
大家应该听说过是非常不错的啊
然后嗯嗯这门呃呃不是这门课啊
这这个作品的作者第一作者叫叫这个
但就是这个人
然后他是我的师弟
他在他在BERKELEY
他是我隔壁组的师弟
然后他跟的老板就是任NG
大家还记得这个人吗
对吧
因为我们games101里面提过光场照相机
没错啊
然后这就是他们的工作
当然当然我的这以前的博士老板
他也参与进来啊
是这么个意思
就是非常优秀的一个工作
我们不会特别提neural rendering
主要是因为现在绝大多数的neural rendering
做不到粮的事情
哪两个事情这大家自己可以回答的
第一real time
只要你用了神经网络
什么东西很少能够有做到real time的
这是没问题的对吗
然后第2quality
因为很多神经网络出来的东西啊
如果你不去首条啊
另外跟大家说一个概念是首条什么意思
基本上来说你做出可能1万张结果
然后可能有呃
比如说1000张是最好的
一把拿出来给大家看
这个做法叫做cherry picking啊
之前是不是跟大家说过呢
我要是没说过的话
我就现在说一下啊
cherry picking的意思就是说
你看你比如说要去樱桃园里摘樱桃
你会剪什么样的樱桃摘呀
你肯定要剪最好的了对吧
然后待遇对于实时渲染来说
你不能做这个事情
为什么
因为这些呃你要显示的什么东西啊
这些是由用户控制的
你是不可能说你把所有的情况都覆盖到
除非你的算法本身就能够把所有东西都覆盖到
而把所有东西都覆盖到
这是神经网络本身的劣势的地方
就是说你的数据集越大
覆盖的东西越多
它就越可能不好训练
甚至可能会出错
对吧
所以说对于real time和high quality
这种neural rendering很可能都做不到
所以说我不是特别愿意提
但是但是有很多成功的神经网络的应用
我会在这门课里面提示
比如说用神经网络去做降噪好吗
然后这么个意思
那么还有一些不会说的是什么呢
还有一些不会说的
就是哎怎么用open gl
那我既然这么一说
大家就应该已经知道了对吧
这门课我们会要求大家用open gl shader language去写呃
一些呃SHA的啊
这个之前我们在games101也提过对吗
我们需要用呃这种着色器语言
然后着色语言啊这个意思
然后呃去去去描述说
让这些顶点和片段着色器应当怎么样去呃工作
对嘛
然后但是呢就是说呃写这些着色器呃
语言跟会用open gl什么东西
这其实我觉得两者应该分开来看啊
open gl本身是一套非常不好用的C加加端的啊
不C风格的这种API啊
然后他能干什么呢
他能帮你
比如说我们在games101里面学的一些什么
那变换矩阵的对吧
比如说我们知道这个透视投影矩阵
给定各种各样的参数对吧
同样把这些参数交给这个API
它自动就可以帮你得出这样一些一些结果
一些一些矩阵啊
以及包括场景的设置
或者别的一些什么东西
所以呢open gl不是一个什么重要的东西
但是呃shader language
是的啊
这是两个不同的事
然后我们待会儿作业那部分还会再继续说啊
然后呢
呃呃我们这门课不会说的
是关于场景和所谓着色器的一些优化
就比如说你现在做了一个游戏
然后他可以跑10FPS
那么怎么样通过各种各样不同的优化
把它给变成30FPS呢
当然这个这个事情是非常难做的哈
呃但是我们是不说的
为什么呢
道理还是一样
我们刚才已经说了
这是一项纯技术的事情啊
因为因为背后你用的科学的这些这些知识
什么东西
这些都是完全一样的
然后作为一个啊优秀的工程师
然后这是你这是你什么呢
其实是应该做的啊
或者说是你主要的工作啊
这个意思
所以关于这块我就不再多说了
另外一点呢
如果你想去这个逆向别人的SHADER
这是我一定不会说的啊
从道义上也不该这么说的啊
这个事情
然后呢关于这门课
如果你想在这门课里面学到一些高性能计算
这个也是我不太说的
比如说你想通过这门课去了解
怎么样去写扩大程序
然后这样而且才能写的快啊
这块呢我也不会特别的呃说啊这个意思好嘞
然后呢哦我看嗯差不多这个时候算是可以
咱们简单停一下啊对吧
我来看大家有什么问题哈
嗯有同学说为什么咱们不用direct x啊
道理很简单
因为他是这个啊不能跨平台吗
如果有同学是Mac或者是呃
open gl肯定就不行了对吧
然后有同学说HLSL啊
真的差不多
HLSL和GLSL这些都是不同的
shader language的BALAN也可以吧
就是说我们待会作业很快就会说啊是啊
我这就告诉大家了
就是web gl的框架
这样的话不涉及到任何平台的问题好吗好嘞
然后有同学说啊
这叫什么呢
后面会不会有录屏啊
啊有我现在不就在做吗
啊
OK有同学说期待离线渲染的课之后看吧
我只要不忙啊
早点
然后有哦
有好多同学跟我一样
打这个这些怪物猎人类还可以
挺好的挺好的挺好的
OKOK来看看嗯
啊有同学说全局光照应当怎么样去入门啊
我觉得吧对于实时渲染中间的全局光照
那就就按这门课来了啊
我尽量把这事情说清楚好吗
然后哦有同学反映说在这个虚幻引擎中
他用的技术并不是我所说的
没问题
这是我愿意跟大家探讨的事情嘛对吧
因为毕竟我也不知道嘛好嘞
然后有同学说SVGF会讲这个很具体啊
SVGF是一个呃具体的去做实时光线追踪
降噪的一个方案
然后这个我们会提啊
会提呃
SVBRDF会讲吗
其实SVBRDF就是BRDF嘛
然后会讲一些啊
呃所谓PB2啊
大家在工业界中这么说的啊
physical bas rendering或者叫physical base material啊
这块会说的没问题
大作业会做什么呢
是随便做的啊
到时候我也会说嗯好的嗯
有什么书的推荐
马上就会说好的啊
有同学在说到底应该如果要学的话
是要学unity还是要学虚幻的
没关系吧
真的我说这两者都是嗯
嗯我觉得哈学完这门课之后应该怎么学
嗯这些都是可以的
虽然从我个人角度上来说啊
我觉得啊REO这做的更酷炫一些
然后结果更好看一些啊
仅仅是这个意思啊
unity的话
以前对于对于科研人员他们的支持是非常好的
它有非常好的一套开发的系统
现在RMONG的话
嗯即便是400
我是觉得因为我带学生们做过一些项目啊
就是说呃我已经觉得不是特别好上手啊
啊real engine呃
不太好上手
作为科研来说嗯
但是一旦上手
比如说你花了两个月去上手这些东西
然后去学他的这些背后的机制
以及他的SHADER该怎么写
然后你会发现是一件非常值的事情啊
没问题
就是他学习曲线非常
这叫什么非常陡啊
这个意思好嘞
嗯那么哎呀好吧
这是什么问题啊
有很多东西我不懂啊
有同学问什么叫超分呢
我不懂啊真的
然后呃工业界上实时和离线的要拿多一些啊
这个看情况啊
比如说像游戏肯定是实时
电影肯定是离线吧
这样好吧
那这样啊
我先放在这儿
然后呢我们先继续后面的话题
因为这次东西比较多哦
啊在这之前先跟大家说一下这个事啊
由于在这之后就是我来控制这一门课呃
一节课要讲多长时间
所以不存在拖堂啊
等我讲完为止了哈
要不我每一次我在km101
我回头听自己的课
我都在跟大家说
这一个小时又讲不完了
行吧哈哈
然后我觉得今天我们一个小时也讲不完啊
所以说我就把这个课程内容讲完就算呃
为什么呢啊是这样的
就是作为这门课来说
我虽然在这边的学校教过
但是作业games202加了很多新内容啊
包括咱们第一节课也有很多新内容
所以说呃关于时间的把握上
我就不按那么严格来处理啊
就是把一个事情说清楚会算
如果时间短了
那就短了
长了就长了对吧
没问题
好嘞好
那么既然这样说了
那咱们就现在呃呃安稳进行后面的内容对吧
我们说了what对吧
然后下面应该是啊哈哈哈Y
但是我们把这Y给嘿嘿嘿放在后面了
我们先说怎么样自学games202吧好吧
然后关于学games202
我个人是这样理解的啊
这就是刚才我跟大家说的啊
我们学校202的过程中一定要记得这件事情
科学和技术是不等同的
当然这件事情是我个人的理解
然后就是说所有的这些课程中间啊
肯定都是老师自己的理解
然后大家也欢迎大家有自己的理解
这么个意思
我认为科学和技术是严格意义上不等同的
两样事情
科学是什么呢
科学代表着知识
你所理解的对于这个世界应当如何去运作
没问题啊
然后技术技术是什么呢
技术更多代表的是技巧
就是所谓的engineering
Skills
工程能力啊
这样说
然后技术是用来干什么呢
是要把科学给转化为产品这么一个意思
而科学跟技术通常人们会简称科技
这是为什么呢
这是因为绝大多数人认为这两件事情
反正我都不懂
随时随是一回事对吧
但对于咱们来说
区分一下science technology
这是两个不同的事情
一个最典型的例子就是车对吧
大家知道汽车这种东西
大家在多长多长时间之前对吧
就已经知道应该怎么样去运作了对吧
但是直到今天
咱们国产的车子性能仍然不是特别那个对吧
所以说啊
就是说这就是所谓技术
在这个背后起到的一个关键作用
所以说科学跟技术不等同
但是我没有说哪一项更重要
技术和科学
我可以认为它们同等重要
那对于real time rendering是什么呢
对于这门课来说
只要你能够记得这样一件事情
就是说啊real time rendering
他所它背后所应用的科学知识
实则就是对离线渲染的一些科学知识的简化
然后能够让它变得更快的一些方法
这些东西我们会教没问题
然后呢
在这在这个背后还需要你去做系统的工程
就是这么个意思
为了达到real time rendering
而这一点我们已经在助教同学的努力之下
给大家简化的非常厉害了
就是说大家在接接到作业框架的时候
很多情况下是直接可以上手到科学这一块
而不是说要涉及到各种各样复杂的这些呃
这些真正的这些实现上就是我所说的嘛
如果让理解
比如说你不用跟阿real比
就跟我比
你可能就会慢那么多倍啊
这么个意思哈
这块呢大家在之后呃
就是呃在之后的学习过程中吧
慢慢的积累
多写代码非常对的
不要管是什么样不同的语言做什么事情对吧
然后基本上来说
就是就是养成一个写代码的好习惯
把自己无论如何培养成一个好的工程师
这是最重要的一件事情
然后然后就是说大家呃我刚才想说什么来着啊
对啊是这么个意思
就是说对于呃实时渲染来说啊
其实有这么一个嗯很奇怪的一个现象
但是呢又可以解释什么呢
就是实时渲染的技术来说
我们大家注意我说的是技术啊
这一块儿在工业界它是远远领先于学术界的
就是通常在在学术界
就是说由博士生论写出来的这些代码
很可能是和工业界大家写出来了这么一些嗯
这些好的
这些代码是没有办法比的
确实是这样的
这是实话
然后这是怎么回事呢
是因为工业界
比如说一些游戏公司
他们自己做游戏的过程中
最早就能够看到最新的问题
没错吧
而这些问题很可能学术界根本都不知道
可能会有这么一个问题
他们根据自己的产品需求会发现这个问题
而发现这个问题
就是由由自己同时再来提出一个解决方案
所以大家可以看到
这是一个非常封闭的一个系统
对不对
在这个工业界里面嗯
然后另外有一点呢
由于涉及到所谓这叫这叫什么呃
英文叫IP啊
叫intellectual property啊
这个东西的限制
或者咱们就理解成版权啊
就这种限制很可能呢工业界和工业界之间
他们就不太交流这件事情
甚至到学术界就是我们有很可能哈就是NVD啊
我不知道攒了有多少神奇的什么技术
没告诉大家
他这是有可能的事情啊
所以是非常封闭的一个系统
呃没问题
那么呃共享的技术就非常有限
所以说同样的一个道理
在学术界我能够接触到的技巧也非常的少
这是实话啊
这是实话
所以我就说我自己能力是非常有限的
我只能说在什么呢
在学术界这边
然后能够把我知道的这些事情告诉大家
然后我相信大家的啊
比如说比如说都是计算机系的同学们
大家的培养体系是一定可以
把大家给变成一个合格的优秀的工程师的
好吧
是这么一个意思
那么咱们在学games202的过程中
专注背后的科学好吧
然后当然实现
这就是你要做到的
把科学和技术融会贯通的时候好吗
差不多这么个意思
那同样这样就可以解释了对吗
有同学会说说
我会不会讲什么一些超级超级经典的技术
比如说deferred shading对吧
大家如果说知道做过这些实时渲染
知道有一个重要的东西叫延迟渲染
然后这是很重要的一件事情
但是他是一个纯技术的事情
所以我在这门课最后啊可能花一点时间提一下
还有比如说什么cascaded的技术
block的技术对吧
有很多各种各样这些啊我想说的是什么呢
就感觉跟大家这个修仙是一个道理的对吧
这招式不是最重要的对吧
然后最重要的是什么呢
应该是内功与这个这叫什么待遇阶品对吧
炼气期是打不过元婴期的对吧
这么个意思诶
嘿嘿嘿行吧行吧行吧啊
那咱们继续啊
然后最后一点
那当然了
这就是说你这个呃呃
多练是对的
刚才已经跟大家说了
practice makes perfect啊
没问题好嘞
OK那这样的话咱们就说清楚了对吧
关于这门课咱们怎么理解
怎么样学啊
这个意思好嘞
然后那如果说你是啊看的是直播啊
我会要求你多问问题
多问问题非常好
如果我没看到的话
我中间我会想办法停下来
然后你再嗯到时候再说一遍啊
不好意思
这事我会尽量的多来关注我们的弹幕
这是一个啊
如果你看的是之后的嗯
呃这叫什么呢
在B站上传的视频呢
然后我会建议你做这么一件事情
我会建议你用1.25倍速
到1.5倍速度来播放我们的视频
为什么呢
是因为我自己啊
我自己知道我自己说话很慢
但是呢我又不知道我说话如此的慢
我自己去看我在B站的视频
我的感觉是啊
如果我按照1.25倍速来播放的话
我觉得那才是我的正常的说话速度啊
这么一个意思
OK啊行了
知道了哈
所以说这个啊道理就在这
然后如果你想稍微快一点
1.5倍可以两倍
可能对于新手来说太快了啊
这么个意思
我自己觉得我非常愿意大家去去哈哈
去播放这个1.25到1.5倍啊
这么个意思呃
当然背后原因是什么呢
我也不知道是不是我说话真这么慢
还是说还是说比如说B站
他会有一个什么24fps到30
FPS这种转换呢
但如果这样的话
时长怎么没加
没有加长啊
这样吧我就不再解释这个事了啊
就是我真的觉得啊1.25倍
大家就把它当成正常速度啊
如果想快一点
非常欢迎
没问题好嘞
那么哎我们故意把这个问题放在最后对吗
Why study games
202对吗
通常这个和我和我后面说的
和我之前说的顺序是反的对吧
我会先说what
然后Y然后再how对吧
然后这次说说这个Y呢是这么回事
就是说大家为什么要学习games202呢
那首先我要感谢大家去学习games101
因为有同学向我反映说啊
这个呃学了games101之后啊
嗯嗯找到了工作啊
或者是说自己对图形学产生了非常好的兴趣
决定之后以后人生方向就是他了
唉我非常感动啊
非常非常感动
这是表示什么呢
表示说呃我这网课也算是帮到大家了
这是以后也会
我也会希望更多的课程能够帮到大家
然后games202呢也会对吧
然后不管你是在学术界还是工业界以后
就不管怎么样能够有所帮助
那就非常好好嘞
然后呢呃如果你就是单纯的诶
我喜欢图形学
我单纯的就想多做一点
对吧啊哈哈
然后这样就会就会会有帮助对吧
然后我觉得我觉得对的没问题
这就是说大家学games202的理由有很多对吧
但是哈我在这里啊哈哈哈哈
一个一个很经典的理由
如果你上过games101
你应该是已经知道了的
对不对
哎好吧
然后请大声的喊出这个理由啊
当然不是异世相遇
尽享美味
哈哈OK好
computer graphics is awesome啊
咱们回到正经的话题上来了
OK行吧
所以说就是说啊对于我来说
我认为我喜欢图形学
我觉得图形学看起来非常酷炫
做出来的东西非常好
然后我就是因为这个我就想想多学一点啊
没问题
哎呀呀嗯
所以说呢我也希望啊
真正通过这节课让大家能够意识到对吧
图形学是一个非常有意思的一个嗯
计算机下面有个分支对吧好嘞
然后这就是这一块了啊
下面呢我们说一说关于这些课程的一些要求啊
不是说要求一些数学上啊
来吧
那第一点呢那就是我要求什么呢
上这门课之前你要有的事情
那就是兴趣啊
就是说这是最重要的
就是你要是不喜欢rendering或者graphics
那上这门课你会觉得挺痛苦的对吧
那多没意思呀对吧
然后呢呃基础基础是什么呢
games101就可以
但是呢不一定是games101
你之前上过任何的图形学课
是肯定是没有问题的好吗
因为任何的图形学课
一定都会告诉你
基础的渲染管线怎么样去运作啊
这就够了
然后呢我们所需要的呃一点点呃微积分知识
我们会在下一节课给大家复习啊
就是基本只需要一些这些问题
我看有同学会问需要不需要什么呢
这什么数值分析啊
别的一些信号处理啊
在这门课里面
其实用老师平常如果真的需要
我们就临时用
临时说好吗
这个意思
所以没有什么必要去再买什么别的书啊
或者去呃上一些其他的这些课
专门为了这门课去打基础
没必要啊
我觉得直接听肯定是可以的
那么另外一个准备的事情就是我刚才所说的
就是我认为那你是有能力直接掌握
open gl本身怎么样去用
以及包括open gl shader language怎么样去写的
OK然后我也也说了
咱们在这个呃就是助教的帮助下
我们只需要基本上来说
只需要你把作业零跑通
就是说下一节课的时候会放出作业
零
很可能会早一些
可能会晚一些的啊
这个意思啊
酷睿零呢不做要求
然后就是大家把它给环境配通
然后嗯把他的代码跑通
你就知道该怎么做了
以后的作业基本就是在写SHADER
着色器
基本不会特别涉及到open gl
然后呢同时着色器语言你说也没有学过
其实你在games101里面
我提过那么111两页的PPT对吧
说呃我们的下一节的
还有下节课也会呃稍微说一点
好吧啊
这么个事儿好嘞
嗯OK麦克能跑吗
有同学问这个事情能啊
能没任何问题
就是我们用WEBGL就是这么一个好处哈
然后就是就是这是完全跨平台的
没有任何问题啊
好那么呃另外一个事情啊
当然我们大家又见到了熟悉的这样
而且又让大家失望了
这门课作为现代化的啊
实时渲染的课是是会覆盖不少内容
但是哈哈它却不需要你用这么好的硬件哈
不需要
真的不需要你用你的笔记本上面的这个显卡
就已经足够了
所以说呢呃就是说你到时候感觉到啊
体现体验到的区别啊
仅仅是最后你写的代码
他的FPS的问题啊
就是跑得快还是慢
就是肯定会受到影响
但是绝对不耽误呃
你去做作业
因为作业嘛我们用的这些这些级别的场景
这些应该都是非常非常非常简单的一些场景
然后就是主要是为了验证说你对呃
这背后的知识是不是理解的对好吗
是这么个意思呃所以你不需要3080啊
或者更好的显卡
哈哈哈哈呃
OK好的
那么这是呃这块吧
然后由于仍然是新课啊
而且要比之前的games2015之前说了
就是新的内容要更多
所以说呃可能还要改的东西会比较多
让大家随时关注什么呢
关注我们的课程网站
课程网站跟之前的呃1011样
但如果大家现在点进去呢
大家会发现一个问题
就是现在还是个占位符
那是因为我现在挺忙
我现在没时间弄这个啊
我会尽快在这节课和下节课之间
把这个网站搭起来
然后我会把什么放上去呢
我会把我们的课程大纲
包括我们每一节课讲过了之后
他的呃呃PPT啊
用PDF形式发出去
然后如果有一些需要读的东西啊
都在这
所以基本上来说啊课程网站上都有好吗
OK好嘞
嗯嗯如果你要买书的话啊
这是挺难为我的一件事情啊
因为因为我不知道这个问题怎么样去回答
因为咱们这门课来说
就首先来说他是个进阶话题
而大家之前所见到的这一些这些这些啊
实时渲染的这些书
他要么就是非常非常进阶
就是假设到呃你你已经完全知道所有东西了
比如说像一些啊SIGGRAPH上每一次的课程
包括这些游戏引擎的设计文档
这些也是我主要来参考的东西
然后之后要告诉大家啊
这么个意思
也是大家之后可能会涉及到的一些呃相关读物
我会给给大家放出来这么个意思啊
嗯如果大家一定要参考的话
有同学会会想到这本书对吗
叫real time rendering这么这么一本书啊
这本书呢倒是没什么
没什么简称啊对吧
大家知道说101的时候
推荐大家去看一下虎书
但是这里我说清楚啊
腐书对于101来说是嗯挺相关的
这样说
就是说基本上来说他还是以另外一些方式吧
算是涵盖了一些
就是嗯图形学入门的很多的内容
但是real time rendering这本书实在太入门了啊
就是这本书来说
绝大多数内容
它是和我们我们这门课讲的不交叉的
好吧我我我这样说啊
就是就是这个意思
所以说这次我特别说一下这个事儿
就是大家真的没必要去有这本书
因为这本书来说它的相关程度啊
比起虎叔对101来说
他对202的相关程度太低了
这么个意思
但是有的话没问题
而且正好可以练一练英文阅读嘛
对不对
挺好的
然后有同学说之后这本书要出中文版是吧
哦那太好了
没问题
所以如果大家想要有这本书
那当然是没问题的哈
嗯OK那么这次呢我们的答疑的平台
除了呃之前games101的论坛之外
还增加了一个QQ群
然后这个Q62群呢
呃呃呃为了容纳这些咱们的这些同学们
我还专门开通了会员
其实现在来说应该可以容纳得了大家吧
我觉得没问题
大家欢迎踊跃参加啊
呃我是在群里面
不过平常可能看的没那么频繁
大家就先讨论着
如果有什么问题的话
诶我就是我闲下来或者怎么着
我会看一眼啊
然后关于BBS也是
然后我们的助教同学和我都会去看一下好吗
嗯OK那么这样的话关于嗯答疑就说了
那么下面就是作业作业怎么办呢
呃作业这次呢呃作业相对少一些啊
相比于嗯相比于咱们的入门课
有这次我们安排五次作业
除了作业零
作业零就不算了
这是呃因为不做邀请吧
除了作业零有五次作业
然后差不多每一次作业呢
你有一个一个星期到一个半星期吧
去完成一个呃作业
然后按我刚才所说的嗯作业的的呃
完成的语言就主要就是呃SHADER
如果呢你要写一些多重pass的一些方法啊
咱们知道实时渲染中间有各种各样就跑一遍
跑一遍嘛
这种就叫pass
然后不同pass的东西呢
你就会在外面的这个啊前端上面来开发
然后这个前端是什么写的
JAVASCRIPT写的
所以大家会看到就是在web gl上面啊
Javascript web gl
然后你要写的东西就是GLSL
然后如果你平常要加一个pass或者干什么
就是JAVASCRIPT的一两句代码
而且这些呢在作业描述中会给大家提供
所以大家平常不不至于说需要关注到
除了SHADER之外的一些特别多的一些东西啊
这么个意思好的啊
群号没关系啊
同学们这之后肯定会放出来了
而且games嘛
games网站
大家这不是随便可以找的嘛
对不对
好的啊
好嗯嗯作业的提交啊
跟上一次不一样的地方是在于说
我们这次不再严格限制11.59
这这就是北京时间了哈
我们限制一个时间啊
这这个时间正好给大家普及一下这个概念
AOE啊
大家知道AOE呢
大家在打游戏的时候
这个叫做area effect对吧
就是范围伤害的意思呃
或者范围效果啊
其实这个意思然后可以就是指一打一大片啊
但是咱们在这个里面这个用词
这是AOE
是指anywhere on earth
意思就是什么呢
呃大家看这个时间
就是说只要现在在地球的任何一个位置上
还在deadline之前
你就能提交啊
咱们这么说清楚啊
这这这这个意思啊
那这样的话呢大家就有更多时间来了
呃做一些作业
当然了
这也是其实没这么少啊
就等于是换了另外一个deadline而已好
然后通常来说
助教同学们会在一个星期之内给大家回复啊
这样那么作业框架长什么样呢
其实已经做出来了
大家可以看一眼
大家会不会发现特别中二对吧
二次元
然后大家会发现还有个很很用心的细节
就是202诶
怎么样
所以说嘛
我觉得这个我们的呃
助教同学们也是是非常非常优秀的同学们啊
然后也非常上心啊
非常感谢
做的非常好
那么大家之后呢
就会在这套框架下继续再去完善大家的作业啊
OK那咱们这就这样呃
关于作业的提交呢还是一样
我们用之前的所谓私彻呃系统啊
然后大家现在就已经可以注册啊
应该没问题
如果我没弄错的话
如果如果大家在注册的过程中遇到什么问题
及时告诉我
但是有一点我先说啊
咱们之前的101的课程中呃
有同学反映这么一个事情
是说用QQ邮箱是不能注册的对吧
我不知道在后续201和102里面
是不是已经把它给改掉了
呃这个我不知道为什么
这可能是这个系统本身它就是这么安排的啊
然后呃然后呢如果大家出现这种不能注册
再去换一个邮箱试试看好吗
呃我希望他已经修复了这个问题啊
那同样道理
咱们这这门课呢不会有考试啊
基本上就是几次作业以及一次大作业
大作业同样道理
差不多中段的时候会放出来给大家一些选项
然后但是大家可以自由的去选择好吗
这是没问题
然后今年呢我们根据时间来看看
有没有办法能够做一个所谓show off环节
给大家展示一下
做的好的呃
就是特别酷炫的呃
结果好吧
然后呢这次主要跟大家说的事情是呃
不是就是有一点和101不一样的地方
在于这里大家如果上过101
应该记得我之前跟大家建议说啊
说我们要学习啊EK的genius部分
而不要学freak的部分对吗
没错
所以我建议大家去用一个用集成开发环境去做
我们的games101作业
但这里我怎么又说不需要了呢
而这个事情啊不矛盾呃
首先IDE如果你不知道的话
集成开发环境类似于什么visual studio之类这些东西啊
就等于说你直接包括编译
包括debug
包括别的这个代码分析
所有东西都在一块了
而他最重要的事情
我之所以games201会建议大家这么用啊
就是说呃因为你涉及到要开发一个工程
你需要知道这些整个的各种各样类之间的
不同的结构对吧
因为整个一个工程可能是几十上百个文件嘛
那么多
然后如果有一个自动分析
自动补全的一个工具
它会非常好啊
是这么一个意思
我是出于这么一个考虑
那么对于这门课为什么我建议说没必要啊
我只是说没必要
我不是说不建议用IDE了哈
呃为什么没必要呢
是因为你这次主要是在写SHADER啊
基本上来说就是单文件嗯
几个文件吧至多了
所以说呢如果是单文件的话
而且SHADER这个语言本身
我觉得大部分id分析的都不太好
所以说嗯这次呢就没有什么必要去用IDE了
一些文本编辑器非常欢迎啊
如果大家用slime text的话
来了这些啊
然后这些都可以
当然大家还可以用回vs code啊
用用一些其他的这些东西啊
绝对没有问题
有一些在线的一些编辑的软件应该也没有问题
所以这次呢是主要是
因为这次大家要集中在一两个文件上面来了
工作啊
这么一个意思啊
OK啊所以不矛盾之后呢
如果大家看情况啊
在不同的课程中开发不同样呃不同的呃作业啊
工程呀
像这些呃根据需要来去选取这个事情好吗好嘞
那OK这样的话啊
这就是呃我要说的关于IDE的事情
那么既然是做作业吧对吧
做作业呢肯定要独立完成
然后还是一样跟之前一样呃
尽量不要把代码框架拿到那拿拿到网络上面去
因为呃这门课呢
以后肯定还会有更多的同学要去要去学习嘛
嗯然后如果说到时候大家提前看到答案
那就不太好了
对吧啊
这是这是这个事情啊
但是欢迎讨论说你要有任何的问题什么这解释
如果有同学有问题
你要回答他
那没有任何问题
好吧啊
OK这就是关于作业的事情啊
我再暂停一下
我来看一下同学们有什么其他的问题啊
OK嗯哎呀
OK好吧
至少我现在所能看到的这些弹幕哈
如果没有
这边哦
有同学说能不能自己写框架
可以啊
欢迎欢迎自己写框架啊
没问题
参考答案的话
参考答案还是够呛的
这个事情
就是说我尽量不是
不是特别希望能够把答案给公布出来
但是我们会给更多的参考图吧
这样就是说你希望比如说每一步的中间结果
你大概能够做到一个什么样
这就对了哈
这么个意思好吧
作业合格会有证书吗
有啊
当然有games的
每一节课
每每一门课都会有啊对吧
卡通渲染啊
之前我说了
卡通渲染肯定是属于非真实感渲染的一部分
它主要是技术环节
我会提它的它的基本做法
但不会具体到呃什么什么效果
怎么实现实现这么一个事情
好会有作业检查诶
什么意思呀
作业就是提交了
当然就有助教助教来批改呀
对不对
好啊哈哈
看起来对就是对的是吗
对于实时渲染来说
还真是这样啊
我这么理解啊
那行啊
那我就继续了
那就是说这刚才讲的那基本上是这节呃
这呃咱们整个一门课
他的最最呃重要的一些内容吧
然后我现在开始来说
咱们这节课要跟大家说的东西呃会挺多的哈
那我就继续了
OK好
那么今天的这个课程内容哈
课程内容要说的是什么呢
呃首先就是说我们要学呃
这门课到底是呃呃为什么要学实时渲染
实时渲染存在的意义是什么
然后就是说它的嗯他的一些发展史
基本上来说咱们就过一遍啊
这个意思这块会非常快啊
啊我我呃
然后呢会给大家列出来一些
就是我会觉得嗯在呃实时渲染的发展过程中
呃一些重要的啊里程碑式的呃成就啊
这么个意思
那咱们就从第一点开始吧
就是说呃目前来说就是渲染来说
咱们大家都已经说了
要做到什么效果呢
PHOTOREALISTIC对吧
就是照片及真实感
咱们之前提过
然后它里面就涉及到大量的一些呃计算要处理
比如说复杂的几何光照材质
然后你要做的阴影
对不对
然后呢嗯在各种各样的领域
比如说电影
然后呃
呃这些里面都会用到一些所谓什么特效啊
这些什么东西对吧
这些都是非常非常呃跟图形学相关的东西
就是大家希望把这些东西做得非常真实
然后大家能不能做到非常真实的能啊
就是就是说大家现在呃对吧
我之前给大家展示过这些这些图啊
都是假的
都是图形学这么渲染出来的
3D建模出来
然后渲染出来大家可以看到非常厉害
对不对
可以是可以
但是咱们今天的一个解释是可以
但是这些方法往往不能够兼顾质量与速度对吧
咱们之前说了
实时渲染就是考虑什么呢
就是要考虑a real time和这个high quality两个都想做到
那所以说呢就是说呃这些就叫做offline rendering
对吧
然后就这些这个呃就是说这些比较慢的方法
但是能够算得准的方法
那我们都管它叫offline rendering
然后之前的一个呃栗子对吧
大家见过
在utopia里面一帧渲染需要多长时间呢
我记得当时给大家的答案是1万个GPU hour啊
Gpu hour
GPU CPU hour啊
这样说不准确啊
CPU CORE hour才是对的
就是一个和要跑上1万个小时
那当然这是一个非常烧钱的事情
对不对
那么对于实时渲染来说
就是要在一些合理的近思想
我们要找到最最最最接近的结果
然后也就是说看起来OK的结果
刚才有位同学说的非常对啊
就是说我就是希望他看起来OK
那么大家可以看到实时啊
离线渲染左边这么一幅图啊
离线渲染的结果是不错的
那么在实时渲染中
比如大家看到最终幻想15
刚开始老师给大家打过
就知道这个车子坏在路上
大家会看到这个车子做的非常的酷炫
当然这种截图截的不怎么好啊
看不出来这车有多么对
这个呃厉害啊
但是这这块儿嗯就是我想说的是实实现实
现在来说做一些牺牲
但是也能够做到一些看起来不错的结果
但是这个事情说起来容易做起来难
就是说你可能做出来了很多假设之后
他看出来了
结果仍然不怎么好
这么个意思就是你如何做出来了
假设越越又少得出来的结果呢
又跟真实的这些啊
我们认为啊离线渲染是真实的
就是跟真实的离线渲染又能够相比
那是最好的
对不对
这就是我们的根本出发点
说呃实现实实时渲染到底是为什么要这么做
对吧好
那么呃实时渲染呢它是呃是有一个怎么说呢
非常丰富的历史吧
甚至来说他可能比离线渲染还要嗯长
我这么理解哈
最早呢大家可以看到这里
就是就是说当时呃很早期的时候
大家就可以用这这些呃实时渲染生成一些什么
大家看起来就很古老的一些这么这么一些图哈
对吧呵呵然后呃这算是挺早的时候了
然后嗯在20年之前
然后实时渲染3D的实时渲染啊
就是进入到了游戏的这个行业里面
呃一个典型的代表就是最终幻想七
最终幻想器当时是在那个呃索尼的PLAYSTATIONY啊
上面发布的时候
当时大家看这个画面
就觉得这个画面已经无敌了
对不对
那咱现在再看这个画面
就会觉得这怎么那么多三角形是吗
哈哈哈哈啊对吧
然后呢同同时代的哈
同时代的有一款这个风靡全球的游戏啊
叫做反恐精英
然后呃然后大家可以看到
仍然是非常非常有限的三角形数
然后当时大家会呃
就是说大家既然我认为如果大家学过games
101了
大家如果当时还打这个游戏还记得的话
他当时甚至连文理的什么啊
嗯就是三线性差值什么东西啊
它它都是一个算是开销很大的一个东西
就是这么个意思
所以说大家可以想象啊
这个实时渲染啊
当时最早的时候啊
是不是非常非常嗯呃看起来不怎么样
但是自从有了那个开始之后
那之后的10年是一个飞速进展的10年
然后这10年呢
就是为什么会得到这么一个飞速的进展
这块是非常重要的一个历史的知识点
那就是在这里由于可编程渲染管线嗯
被呃研究出来
或者说发布出来啊这么一个意思
也就是说人类可以自由的去控制
说我这块渲染到底应该怎么样让它进行着色
那这就是呃
给编程人员提供了非常非常大的便利
那么这样的话就可以得到非常好的效果
也就是花了10年左右的时间
大家就可以看到刺客信条二里面
大家就可以看到非常不错的结果了对吗
然后呢大家会看到同时代还会有一个游戏
生化危机五
然后大家会看到呃这两款游戏诶
即便今天看来
我觉得是不是还是不错的对吗
然后如果说同学们没上过games101
会觉得说哎
那我觉得今天游戏可不也是这样吗
呃然而不是对吧
在games101
我之前提过一个怎么样判断
说实时渲染渲染的好还是不好的一个标准啊
还记得吗
就是看画面是否足够明亮对吧
比如说左边这一幅呃
这个结果刺客信条它的最大的问题就是
这分明是一个白天晴朗的一天
但是为什么在阴影的地方里面这么暗对吧
这就是显然是实时光照做的
还是稍微差那么一些啊
这个意思
然后呢在最终幻想啊
最终幻想这叫生化危机啊
生化危机五里面他的问题在哪里呢
这就是平常人们通常会说的另一个问题
这里再跟大家说一下
叫做油啊
然后什么叫油呢
大家可以看到这个这是第一关大boss啊
他的他的胳膊啊
他的胳膊上面他的这块人家这个反射
这就不太真实
就感觉不像是衣服正常应该反射出来的
对不对
难受这么一个意思
然后就就会就会觉得看起来非常油
有很多这种这种效果的
大家会看到在嗯之前的10年的游戏里面
这这样的效果会越来越少啊
这个意思也就是说画面是在不断进步的
只不过你会觉得说这个进度可能没有
不是30年到呃
不是20年到10年前这样的一个进步大啊
这么一个意思好吧
就看起来非常油啊
这么个意思啊
一个是看起来暗
一个看起来油
这是当年的一些游戏的问题
那么到了今天
当然这已经不算是今天了啊
2018年大家可以看到诶虚假的战神这里啊
然后大家可以看到这些效果基本上就没了
对不对
画面非常的明亮
然后大家可以看到这个奎爷他的这衣服上面
什么东西
它就没有那种非常非常不自然的高光了
对吧好啊
OK所以说呢呃现在大家追求的是什么呢
叫做stunning graphics
对不对
就是说嗯嗯真正的这叫什么呢
就是stunning怎么翻译啊
啊唉就非常好吧啊
就是这样了
就是OK那就这咱们就先这样
就是说呃
现在啊大家需要追求的就是stunning graphics
然后呢我还想提一下
就是real time rendering啊
他在现在来说应用的更加广泛了
这一点呢倒是说呃和我们之前所说的
整个游戏的这一脉是不太一样的
什么呢
就是现在的实时渲染嗯
被广泛应用在虚拟现实和增强现实里面
呃比如说大家看到这款游戏对吧
这是虚拟现实的一个游戏
当然大家可以看到
受制于啊这些移动设备呢呃表现能力
然后他们会有有很大的画质上的牺牲
当然这也就给了实时渲染的一些呃
更多的研究机会是非常不错的
然后呢一个更有意思的事情
甚至以后可能成为一个趋势哈
这里是什么呢
是已经有人开始用实时渲染的技术去制作
平常我们认为只有离线渲染技术
可以做的电影了啊
或者说是连续剧啊
就是说所谓animation啊
就这些已经可以用啊
这些呃实时渲染的技术来做了
比如说大家刚才看到的虚幻引擎五对吧
虚幻引擎五大家看起来了诶
他这个做的已经完全是电影级别的画面了嘛
对不对
这么好
就算他慢点没关系
那我用它来生成一个电影来说
我是不是就不需要一个所谓CPU farm
然后一堆CPU在一块烧钱呢
对不对
我就可以用实时渲染的方式
然后我来生成整个一部电影
那就非常好
我觉得以后肯定会就是短期的几年内
就应该可以看到这个呃
更多呃用实时渲染的方式
然后制作的这些电影是什么东西的好吧
另外一点呢就是说呃在实时渲染上
大家可以看到
这是之前另外一个虚幻引擎的一个例子啊
就是虚幻引擎有很多炫技的一些一些例子
这个例子我非常喜欢
为什么呢
是因为他呃看起来非常有美感啊
然后就是说整个这个场景又真实又又又有美感
当然大家已经从叶子的边缘
在所谓depth of field之外的区域
模糊的区域
看到叶子边缘已经不怎么特别真实了对吧
但是大家可以看到这草地这个啊树啊
这算是蜗牛吗啊
其实我一直一直不知道那东西怎么念啊
就是纲手召唤出来的那个东西啊
然后大家可以看到这个苔藓对吧
嘿嘿嘿嘿
OK咱们就咱们就到这了啊
就是说这块嗯差不多就是说呃可以做的非常好
然后大家可以看到这个例子
大家之前肯定已经见过了对吧
实时渲染实时光线追踪的例子
那么这里呢有大量的这种很闪耀的一
些反射对吧
然后这就是这个例子做出来
就是说呃
那正是之前的这些所谓图像空间的一些方法
是做不到的
然后说我们都会说啊
那咱们这就得这个也就看到这儿啊
那么未来呢未来是一个什么样的情况呢
没有人知道对吗
未来也许是会像黑俄帝国一样啊
我们之前在games101的最后给大家说过
这事儿对吗
就是说啊啊
就是就是就是未来会不会是由所谓graphics people啊
然后做出来整个一个世界
然后可以统治所有人哈哈非常好的一个愿望哈
然后包括大家也可以看到说这个之前ready player one
头号玩家对吧
这里面的整个这个世界吧
基本上来说就是由一个非常破败的现实世界
和一个非常非常嗯厉害的虚拟世界组成的
然后他们这个设备叫ASIS对吧
而且不只是有这个观感
还还有触感
这个是非常厉害
OK好吧
这个也就看一眼好了
然后呢呃这就是快到最后了哈
咱们这节课的最后嗯主要是说什么呢
这么长时间的发展
有哪些技术是非常非常重要的
那首先有一点肯定就是要说的是
这个可编程的渲染管线
就是20年之前呃
vertex shader和fragment shader
这两个着色器
已经就是可以由呃编程人员自己来写了
那就非常好
就提供了非常厉害的一个呃可能性
那么这里其实是一个例子啊
这就不给大家放了
这是嗯就是当时早期的
但是那个时代啊看起来了
简直了跨时代的东西
然后呢可编程渲染管线
咱们早就已经跟大家讲过了对吧
就是关于所谓的嗯
就是vertex的processing阶段对吧
然后fragment processing阶段就是顶点和片段的着色
然后现在呢当然更多的部分都可以被呃
拿来编程
甚至还有一些通用的编程的着色器
叫做叫做计算机端
我不知道是不是这么翻译
compute shader啊
然后就是说我们这门课来说
就是说涉及到呃图形学的相关科学的部分
我觉得是没有必要用到这么复杂的这些实现的
我我我嗯大概我考虑了一下啊
关于我们的嗯
这些作业里面基本上还是只需要用到呃
顶点和片段啊
差不多这么两个事情
那咱们下一节课的复习
基本上也是主要是这个内容好吗
嗯然后另外一个非常非常重要的东西是什么呢
就是呃预计算预计算的这样这样一套理论
就是我们刚才跟理论
跟大家已经提到这件事情了对吗
就是说我可以把很多复杂的一些啊要的效果啊
在渲染之前我就把它算好
然后呢我利用一些存储上的代价
我让我在渲染的时候可以达到实施
也就是说我把他的计算机的这些复杂的地方
可以转移到渲染之前
那我在渲染的时候就可以变得非常快了
是不是这么个思路对吧
那所以说大家可以看到
这是这是当时做出来了一些非常不错的效果
包括那个跳舞机器人啊
然后嗯就是以及包括大家看到这么一个例子啊
然后大家可以看到那个时代
就是应该是微软亚研院做的这个论文哈
非常厉害
然后这个这一个金属的龙还可以在上面画啊
是实时的在上面画
然后还可以在这个地板上画
地板上还可以磨出来一些东西啊
可以看到非常非常高端的一个栗子
然后大家可以看到一个恐怖的东西是什么呢
是他的FPS
看左上角
这可是那个时代啊
那个时代是二代FPS啊
想一想现在来了对吧
所以说预计算这个东西非常重要
而且预计算呢这块我说他还有一个
这个怎么说呢
我值得说的一件事情啊
就是说在预计预计算
就是当时是主要由所谓球面斜波函数
这一系列的奇函数
然后他们的发展来推动的
而首次把球面斜坡函数引入到图形学中的
正是我博士的老板
然后RAVIRAMSAY教授啊
他是厉害的不行的一个人
相当于是引领了一个时代的人啊
OK啊好
所以说这里说一下这个这个事情啊
就是说他可以做这种呃
这种各种各样不同的应用啊
这里当然是另外一种应用
我们之后再给大家说吧
今天时间还是稍微有限一点
那么另外一个事情呢
呃嗯就是一个重要的里程碑式的东西
我的理解是什么呢
是interactive级别的光线追踪
就还不是现在的实时光线追踪
就是在八到10年前啊
就已经有人可以做呃这样一个事情吧
什么呢
就是相当于我在GPU上
我用非常低的采样率
然后我去得到一个呃
呃某一个比较就造成很多的一个结果
然后但是我之后可以快速的做一遍降噪
然后在很多GPU的加持下
我就可以把它呃就就可以做得非常好
就是实时的一个呃
将近实时吧
就是或者说interactive级别这种速度的渲染
然后甚至PIKA呢
当时很早的时候就拿这些东西拿过去
给艺术家们去帮助设计场景
因为这样的话
他们可以更快的就可以看到这个场景之后的
结果是什么样的
如果真的好好渲染了之后
包括现在大家也还在这么用
那也就是说实时光线追踪
其实它的理论基础很早就已经有了
在八到10年前
那么现在来说
实时光追踪在这种硬件的这种突破下对吧
增加了这个RTR的这么一些东西
能够更快地进行光线追踪
那么它背后的重大的挑战又是什么呢
那咱们之后会说好吧好嘞
那这就是差不多我理解的就是之前的一些啊
一些所谓里程碑式的发展
当然我也没说real time retreating
现在不是啊
只不过我们想想说什么东西是里程碑
它得经得起时间考验
现在来说可能还是早了一点
但我相信他是这个意思
那么到此为止大家有什么问题吗
我来看看啊
嗯有同学说我后期会不会讲spherical harmonic啊
这这这意思啊
球面斜坡函数
Spherical harmonics
简称SH会讲啊
会讲computer shader不会提这个意思呃
硬件方面优化不会讲啊
然后啊OK啊
录播
录播之后会有的啊
我看一下哈
啊有同学说会不会说粒子效果会啊
会提到一点点
作为可能最后一两节课说一下这些技术吧
啊然后像这些烘培效果这些不是叫效果了
就是方法什么的
也多少会提一些
这作为一个重要的
也算是预计算的一部分好吗
然后我来看看啊
后面呃呃本课主要在写SHADER嘛
不太合适啊
但是你确实在做这件事情
主要在学学的背后的东西啊
这个意思嗯
工业界做研究
这个我不知道啊
工业界做研究有很多限制的
这也是我为什么不去工业界的原因嘛
嗯OK嗯嗯后期处理会也会提到一点点啊
会提到一点点嗯
三维重建和实时渲染有关吗
没关啊
这是他们完全没有关系
但是啊我正好在为黄金星老师做一个广告
后续的课程games啊
这干涉多少了
203了
我记得是他来说那个吧
来说呃呃三维的实时重建吧
应该是这一三维视觉对整个三维视觉啊
水体渲染能达到实时嘛
能嘛
我猜能
但是你得看做到什么样的效果对吧
你之前打过刺客信条黑旗吗
不是做的挺好的吗
海战的那些海对吧
光照估计是什么呀
我都没听说过什么叫光照估计啊
VFX又是什么呀
这可能会这可能偏工业界偏的多了一些哈
然后我尽量我也多学习一下对吧
向大家学习一下这些这些概念都是什么
也许是嗯我只是另外一种嗯
怎么说另外一个名字在在学同一个概念
KNP2学习资料没有
我还真不知道这块
但是问得好
但是问得好啊
就是我想想办法
我也找一找吧
好吧
等到讲的时候
到时候我看能不能提供一下嗯
OK嗯还有一系列的新课吗
我是没了哈
如果我之后要再开离线渲染的课
肯定还是二开头
甚至我会我会拿他
如果有的话
会愿意拿三开头
因为它会难一些啊
这个意思好吧好嘞
差不多吧啊
然后就是说我觉得今天呢就差不多都说到了哈
然后啊呃下一节课说什么呢
糙快猛复习哈哈这个一些重要概念嗯
比如说之前我们所提到的渲染管线
以及特别是这些着色语言
我说的更详细一点
然后复习一下渲染方程和基本的微积分知识
那么差不多就这些好吗
那所以101202303404吗
同学你这反应也太快了
这是行行行啊
OK啊
那么今天就到这儿了哈
今天就到这儿了
那咱们的呃政客就算是结束了
那另外有一点呢
就是由于我现在呃算是自己掌握这个直播课程
到时候呢呃我会啊
我会把我会把什么呢
我会把这边呃视频及时上传到B站上啊
所以呃OK那就先谢谢大家啊
今天到此结束
Ok
诶OK虽然我关了这个队
但是由于我现在自己在播
我好像
好没问题没问题
那这样哈
如果同学们还有些什么其他问题的话呢
呃那下一节课还是一样的
找个什么5分钟10分钟来啊
大家都欢迎问我好吗啊
就这样啊嗯行
同学们再见
我下播了哈
拜拜